first he's a third term US rep from
Texas 1/16 who's the Democratic nominee
for Senate against Ted Cruz Congressman
Beto O'Rourke okay
did you stack the audience here with
people doubt this out well they seemed
to know who you are already it's like
when the Beatles came to America they
didn't know everybody would know them so
for a well we're just learning a lot of
people so first of all I'll explain the
name so born Robert Frances O'Rourke in
El Paso Texas fourth-generation but like
almost anyone born Robert Nell Paso
called Beto from day one it's a nickname
for Beto or for Robert or Alberto or any
any name ending and barrier faux Irish
pretty Irish especially tomorrow okay
and you're running against Ted Cruz okay
the Ted Cruz we know is very disliked
let me read some quotes Al Franken said
like - I like Ted Cruz more than most of
my other colleagues like Ted Cruz and I
hate Ted Cruz Bob Dole and 2015 said
there are a lot of good candidates I
like nearly all of them except Cruz
right John Boehner Lucifer and the flesh
never worked with the more miserable son
of a [ __ ] in my life Lindsey Graham if
you killed Ted Cruz on the floor of the
Senate nobody would convict you
my question my question is how bad are
you gonna feel if you lose to that guy
yeah yeah I'll tell you there's
something though happening in Texas
right now I've traveled to 226 of the
254 counties people are so fired up
regardless of party or geography so it's
Democrats coming out for sure but it's
also Republicans and independents it's
in the really big cities it's in the
real small towns the places that no one
has ever visited including Ted Cruz
because for the first four years he was
in the Senate he was actually in Iowa
and New Hampshire and South Carolina and
Nevada visited all 99 counties of Iowa
right and so there are places where they
haven't seen a US senator and so when we
show up hold a town hall meeting listen
to the people that we want to serve and
represent we're really making a
connection and folks are committing
themselves to the work ahead and I think
we've got a great shot of winning in
November always wonder why Texas and
California very similar Latino
demographics I think the eligible Latino
voting number here in California is 28%
same as Texas why are we so blue and
Texas is not blue it's only 43% white
now Texas is that right that's right
Texas is one of the most gerrymandered
states in the Union it is also a non
voting state and those two things are
connected there are some people voting
that's right or 49th in the country in
voter turnout the courts four times
alone last year found that our
gerrymandering is in part based on race
and ethnicity there's some people who
are not supposed to vote there's some
people's voices that are not supposed to
be heard it's on us to run a campaign
that brings in everyone from every
community every community within every
community into this campaign to make
sure that they're heard and that they're
actually leading what we're doing I
think when we do that we're gonna give
people a reason to vote and we saw the
greatest Democratic primary midterm
Senate turnout last Tuesday in 36 years
we saw yeah
so folks ooh but the Republicans came
out in Texas to the shirt a bigger
numbers you know what we don't have this
is not in the bag by any means not at
all no and and you know what that's a
great thing because folks from both
parties independents as well are getting
off the sidelines and into the game they
recognize that this year everything that
they care about everything that they've
told their kids about this country is on
the line and for Amy and me that's what
motivated us we anticipate the question
our kids Ulysses and Molly and Henry are
gonna ask us when you had the chance to
do something in 2018 when they were
talking about walls and Muslim bands and
the press is the enemy of the people
what did you guys do and we're gonna
tell them that we and the 28 million of
Texas helped this country get back on
track and on the right direction so
and you don't you don't take PAC money I
don't take a dime of PAC money anybody
who's watching it might not be a
political junkie what is PAC money so
what does that mean political action
committees represent the corporations
and interests that have business before
Congress so the pharmaceutical industry
is the telecom industries the energy
industries the insurance industries and
they give money to members of Congress
not just for access although that's part
of it they're also buying outcomes an
actual legislative language that appears
in the bills and the bills that become
laws when you wonder why Congress is so
dysfunctional why it doesn't represent
the interests of the people it purports
to serve it's because it's so tied to
the sources of money that are coming in
it is those corporations it's why
pharmaceutical prices continue to rise
it's why were the least insured country
in the developed world it's why we're
missing out on so many great
opportunities to do the big important
ambitious work before us and for
Democrats especially it's not enough to
decry citizens united and say that all
this big money sloshing through the
halls of Congress is bad we've got to
start walking the talk and so in this
campaign we have outraised Ted Cruz by
well more than a million dollars without
taking a dime from PACs
but but don't forget he's a giant
[ __ ] that's true but folks so we'll
never have to wonder who it is I
represent or who I'm voting for it's
gonna be the people of Texas so every
single time what would you say are your
top three of you to say your top three
most important issues facing this
country yeah what are yours too many
people can't find a job or in a job
right now that does not pay a living
wage and they need the dignity in the
function and purpose that come number
one is ours number two if you're not
healthy enough to go to that job or
finish your education or raise your
family you're not doing yourself any
good you're not doing the rest of us any
good so universal health care the
ability for everyone to see a doctor so
you're for single-payer if that's how we
get there that's how we get there I'm
open to what a big if if that's how we
get that's a big issue to go I think
Medicare works really well it's overhead
cost as 2% you compare that against
private insurance companies sixteen
seventeen percent it's effective it's
efficient I think that's a great model
so you're where Bernie Sanders is with
healthcare yeah I think he's got a good
plan and I would support his bill in the
Senate I'll tell you I'll tell you
another issue where Texas I think is
uniquely positioned to lead we are the
most diverse state in the country I'd
like to think we are the defining
immigrant experience the city I
represent El Paso Texas is one of if not
these safest cities in America and a
quarter of those that I represent were
born in another country they chose us
they're making us stronger safer more
secure we should be the ones leading the
fight for immigration reform rewriting
immigration law in our own image from
our own traditions and values
and interests Ted Cruz was the sole
senator out of 98 who showed up to work
that day a month ago the sole senator to
vote no unjust proceeding on debate and
discussion to be able to protect
dreamers and allow those more than 1
million of our fellow Americans to
contribute to their full potential to
the success of this country we need a
senator who leads on those issues okay
so so jobs is your one health care is
your - what was your three immigration
immigration Wow so Russia and the
environment then we'll make the top
three Russia in the environment are
really important I mean here's another
four or five yeah there you go here's
here's one where Texas can lead listen
you know us as an energy state right and
we're proud of that a lot of good jobs
in the oil and gas industry in the
refining industry but we're also leading
the country right now in the generation
of wind power we will soon lead the
country in a generation of solar power
there are more clean energy jobs in the
state of Texas today than there are
carbon energy jobs in the state of Texas
a and it's not even close so whether it
is saving the planet for the generations
that follow us recognizing that maybe
manmade climate change didn't cause
Harvey but man-made climate change will
ensure that there are more Harvey's that
they are more frequent they're more
intense there are more droughts in the
Panhandle we have less opportunities to
grow our own food and pass this planet
on to the next generation whether it's
jobs whether it's economic growth for
all the right reasons in the world Texas
can and should lead on environmental
issues for this country and
and what about weed I asked for a friend
yeah
no but I mean look I love Texas i Texas
knows how to party I've gone there as a
guest no he's a comedian for like 35
years you become del paso I've many
times I love El Paso San Antonio Austin
Dallas Houston they're all great cities
they're all fun places and they love
their weed California finally took the
plunge Texas seems like the kind of
place where it's a tough tough row to
hoe there what were you on that one
I've joined a bill written by a
Republican colleague former prosecutor
who waged the war on drugs saw how
futile it was from the front lines to
end the federal prohibition on marijuana
so legal in Texas is it should be and we
should control and regulate yeah sale
and listen we have unites people we have
the world's right no no they smoke it in
the city they smoke it in the country
the hippie smoke it the redneck smoke it
it's it is a it is a uniting thing and
I'll show you after the show I'm kidding
the right thing we have the world's
largest prison population bar none we
have folks who are wasting away behind
bars yeah you raisin families working
paying taxes starting jobs torn and punk
rock bands writing novels whatever
they're supposed to do right and life
looks let's allow them to do all right
come on I'll be rooting for you and I
know they will all right
[Applause]